merci merci madame la présidente ma
question s'adresse au premier ministre
ce prix ministre les chiffres du chômage
d'octobre viennent de tomber comme un
couperet
quarante deux mille chômeurs en plus
c'est la pire hausse depuis deux ans la
france compte désormais 3 millions huit
cent mille chômeurs aujourd'hui même
l'allemagne vient de publier son plus
faible taux de chômage depuis la
réunification
avec 6,3 pour cent de chômeurs l'italie
a annoncé avoir créé deux cent soixante
mille emplois et l'espagne 550000 nous
depuis le début du quinquennat
c'est sept cent mille chômeurs de plus
les raisons en sont connues et votre
politique ne marche pas d'abord la
formation professionnelle qui est en
panne on le sait la complexité du droit
du travail français
avec ses dix mille six cents articles
que vous peinez à réformer puisque
apparemment le dossier qu'on qualifiait
d'urgent n'avance pas votre politique
assez cohérente sur le terrain puisque
vous demander aux collectivités locales
d'être vos partenaires
mais vous ne finance et pas par exemple
les maisons de l'emploi vous des
finances et plus et vous multipliez les
procédures administratives et les
retards de paiement pour les acteurs de
terrain ainsi l' équilibre financier des
missions locales est en jeu à titre
d'exemple la mission locale de marseille
qu'une des plus grandes avec la seine
saint denis expérimente avec vous la
garantie jeunes et nous n'arrivons même
pas à nous faire payer par l'état pour
les travaux effectués déjà depuis
quelques mois ou quelques années et
notamment sur les fonds social européen
vous savez parfaitement monsieur le
premier ministre que nous avons des
retards de plusieurs années d'argent
reçues par l'europe mais toujours pas
versée par l'état ça représente des
sommes énormes pour les collectivités
locales qui ont joué le jeu et notamment
pour la garantie jeunes et ça nous
oblige même à marseille à saisir les
tribunaux mistre hâtif comme
vingt-et-une autres missions locales à
la demande des autorités
mais on nous annonce maintenant monsieur
le premier ministre de compléter ce
qu'on appelle le millefeuille actuelle
c'est le conseil économique et social
qu'il indique qu' ce millefeuille en
créant maintenant de la nouvelle zone 0
territoire zéro chômage zéro de chômage
longue durée
surpris ministre va question est simple
temps comptez vous mettre un petit peu
denses
dans ses politiques et passer à l'action
merci la parole est à madame la ministre
du travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député dominique tian vous
le savez pour faire baisser durablement
le chômage il faut deux préalables
le premier c'est la croissance sur les
trois premiers trimestres 2015 cette
croissance est à 1,1 pour cent le
deuxième c'est que l'économie crée de
l'emploi
en un an nous avons cinquante mille
créations nettes d'emplois cela montre
qu'il ya une confiance qui repart mais
que les chefs d'entreprises sont
aujourd'hui prudent puisque ces
embauches se font majoritairement en cdd
ou en intérim et c'est ce qui explique
les variations extrêmement forte d'un
mois à un autre et vous le savez pour
conforter cette confiance en direction
des entreprises c'est tout le sens du
projet de loi travail que je porterai au
premier semestre 2016 qui vise justement
à permettre de renforcer l'adaptation
des entreprises au plus près et qui vise
concrètement justement à ce que celles
comptant soit moins timide avec le pack
de responsabilité avec le cic et cette
réforme du droit du travail du code du
travail nous permettra justement de
restaurer cette confiance et nous y
parviendrons
depuis le début de l'année il le chômage
des jeunes a diminué de 20 milles et la
garantie jeunes que vous citez y est
pour beaucoup
en effet la garantie jeunes est un
dispositif auquel on tient auquel je
tiens auxquelles les collectivités
locales tiennent auquel les entreprises
tiennent également auquel les missions
locales tiennent il y a eu 35 mille
jeunes en garantie jeanne y en aura
soixante mille entrées supplémentaires
l'an prochain
s'agissant du problème que vous soulevez
notamment du fonds social européen
je vous rappelle que s'agissant de les
bouches du rhône que la commission
européenne a levé notamment à lever a
prononcé la levée de la suspension que
mon ministère a réagi notamment en
permettant aux différents objectifs et
enfin
sachez que restaurer la confiance des
entreprises ciblées les formations vers
le public en a le plus besoin et
travailler en direction des jeunes
sortis du système scolaire voilà quelles
sont nos priorités
merci pour le groupe radical